let me inform you of what the entire
anime community on Twitter has been
yelling about for the past week sailor
Moon's colors to make a very long story
short sailor Moon's home relase colors
have been messed up for a while now due
to the same film aging issues that
plague many of the other anime of the
era like Dragon Ball Z that I've spoken
on extensively but for some reason when
a recent fan project took to restoring
the series to its original colors a huge
chunk of the internet decided that that
was evil and wrong that they love the
super pink Hues of Sailor Moon that that
was what made the series except okay
here's the problem the original TV
airings and DVD releases of Sailor Moon
had the original True Colors these pink
tones only came relatively recently with
more modern releases and for those of
you wondering no the pinkness is
absolutely 100% not the intended colors
there's about three bajillion animation
cells you can find online and around the
world to let you know just that